a diferencia de muchos reportes
iniciales que hablaban sobre que esto
era un tema rutinario o que no sabía
ella se ha confirmado de que si se hizo
labor de inteligencia para secuestrar
estas personas sabiendo que eran
norteamericanos porque venían de la
construcción angulación de un orfanato y
de las donaciones que habían llevado
pues andaban con menores de edad y se
quemaron unas gomas se hicieron
barricadas en ciertas rutas
internacionales para que no pudieran
tener atravesar por las vías principales
y cuando los desviaron pues entonces los
secuestraron o sea que fue un tema
planificado y ese ya hay reporta mente
que tanto las autoridades de los eeuu
como autoridades haitianas están en
contacto con algunos representantes o
intermediarios de esta peligrosa banda
que son los 400 muchos recordemos
también hace dos meses cortaron unos
franceses y hace apenas un mes se
cortaron también unos camioneros
dominicanos controlan todo ese paso
porque un paso que está prácticamente
cerca a la frontera dominicana y por eso
también se ha activado un operativo
especial
para tratar de detectar cualquier
actividad sospechosa o intermediar o
cualquier intercepción de estas personas
que se entienden ya están viendo un
rescate por ello pero increíblemente era
un secuestrado de manera planificada
específicamente porque sabían que era
norteamericanos